things are truly genuinely honestly not
going well for Donald Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen you probably
remember that the FBI raided his office
and his hotel room and I believe his
condo as well not long ago and law
enforcement collected a ton of documents
during that raid a couple of months ago
and the government has turned over
nearly four million seized documents so
far - Michael Cohen's attorneys to
figure out is there privileged
information in any of these 3.7 million
documents and some of the documents that
the FBI found had been shredded and the
latest news is that the FBI is now
piecing together the shredded documents
and of course they're not doing this by
hand there are now computer programs
that can do this and at this point it
has gotten so insane that Trump's
attorneys attorneys are working around
the clock reviewing the four million
documents that the FBI has given them
and not only are there unshredded
documents and shredded documents which
we'll talk about in a second there are
also hard drives and thumb drives and
many many Blackberry phones so it's an
endless sort of treasure trove of
possible evidence of crimes and
originally Cohen's team was given until
June 15th to go over the nearly four
million documents his lawyers are
understandably saying we need like way
way way more time to do this so I want
to focus in for now since it could be a
while until we actually learn more about
the contents of these documents about
the meaning of these shredded documents
and I understand you hear shredded
documents and many people think you
shred documents to hide stuff not
necessarily right I mean attorneys do
shred documents regularly for non
sketchy reasons but yeah if I'm the FBI
I'm looking very very closely at the
documents that Michael Cohen has
shredded and former FBI analyst Asha
ranga tweeted about this quote i've
watched people pieced together shredded
documents it's amazing this is not going
to end well for the defense and former
prosecutor renato Mariotti also on
twitter saying federal prosecutors are
piecing together pages
papers shredded by Michael Cohen that is
bad news for him and one of the funniest
things about all of this is that most
lawyers have moved to what's called
crosscut shredding like you might
remember sometimes seeing vertical strip
shred shredders right this is where you
run a page through it and it shreds a
document into these strips those are
easier to reconstruct with the software
that now is available but most lawyers
now have moved to crosscut crosscut not
Krosh crosscut shredders which read in
multiple directions according to stormy
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti Cohen
had the old strip shredders that he was
using a transcript from his interview
with CNN has Jake Tapper saying let me
ask you a question
federal prosecutors say they're putting
together papers that have been shredded
by Michael Cohen do you know anything
about those papers and Michael avenatti
responding yesterday from what I've
gathered Michael Cohen was so cheap he
didn't invest in a crosscut shredder
which would have made it impossible for
investigators at Quantico forensic
specialists at Quantico to refabricate
or reconstitute these documents
evidently he had a different type of
shredder so they're in the process of
going through it from what I heard in
court today if true it is truly stupid
Watergate and I don't think I have to
remind anybody that if indeed the
shredded documents were related to what
the FBI is looking into and the
shredding took place after Michael Cohen
knew that the FBI was looking into it
that's the possible crying a crime of
destruction of evidence so it is really
not looking good for Cohen right now
well I mean come on Michael Cohen can't
afford a crosscut shredder his three
clients right one is Sean Hannity who
apparently gave him 10 bucks at a party
once and that's it and the other is
Donald Trump who never pays his legal
bills and remember Cohen had to pay for
the story me Daniels hush money so yeah
I can't afford that apparently we can't
expect him to get that fancy shredder
make maga not make America great again
my attorneys getting arrested one
possibility also make America great
again
no it's making attorneys get attorneys I
like both that's much better yeah not
good for Michael Cohen indictment when I
think probably pretty soon the video you
just finished watching was made
possible by you through the membership
program you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership we
are viewer supported independent media
you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership